foreign
[Music]
Clarkson show is kicking off season four
here in New York city so come on the
journey with us weren't you
[Music]
we are premiering
let's go
[Music]
all right y'all we are behind the scenes
of my season four premiere Kelly shoot
today we are actually recording the
video for four songs from the premiere
open medley and I want you to guess them
uh but I'm going to give you a hint to
guess one of the artists so here you go
that's it that's all we're gonna give
you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah okay
you're a little disappointed
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
hi
today it's been going fabulous we are
doing all of these things our show is
all about connection so we really are
you know making everything super
inclusive making sure everybody's
invited to the party the barbecue and so
yeah and where there's music and I'm not
going to tell you the songs that you
gotta watch
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it to her so the bus that's out front
here we're gonna go out there and do a
thing so what are you looking for here
are you looking for a voice you're
looking for a duet partner are you just
having fun with it well we're having fun
with it because this is the thing like
you know I have I have been singing with
celebrities on the show during it but I
thought it would be cool to just like
find people that were me
hey what's up
[Applause]
we are so excited to be here again it's
the season for Premiere week
City once again look at this beautiful
view that we have out here all we need
is Kelly and a show and we've got magic
all right so we are shooting five shows
in two days here in New York like we did
last year
um and it's busy but we're ready right
Gina we're ready we're ready we're ready
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
I get to be on the Kelly Clarkson show
in New York City I'm excited I I have
done Kelly once before and it was so fun
she's such a joy I can't wait to just
see her and hang out with her again
Darcy card and yeah
hey
[Music]
everybody
[Applause]
what's up
um what are you doing here oh well I
mean you said you were looking for some
amazing vocalists so I figured out all
right we're walking the stage Garth you
ready to go for day one of Kelly yes man
it's gonna be fun
[Applause]
we're heading it over it's gonna be
Mike's and get ready for the class until
the concert for the show
oh sweet thank you very much
play it there okay and if the spirit
moves you fine yeah my problem is I use
this to hide my guts the only reason I
have a guitar actually I use my arms
so we just finished season Four's season
premiere um here in New York City I love
this city so much um I had so much fun
with Garth I wish y'all could know how
amazing he is he won't let you tell all
these things because he just does it
because he's genuinely a great guy but
he has literally the nicest human ever
in the kindest and it's incredible and
that's why he's been so blessed
um and then to just have Heroes on at
the end of it I mean that was incredible
Nathan day like and his wife like come
into the rescue that was the crystal
that was amazing and and it's just a I
love being back because I love having
those feel good stories again I miss
those this summer we're back to work
though
I'm so excited because I'm about to
interview secretary Clinton and Chelsea
Clinton I'm very very excited
um and Lord of the Rings cast today I'm
very excited about today so and I'm also
excited with Kelly o'kee's they're two
of my favorites so hope you like them if
you don't well it's already done so
laughs
I'm on Kelly Clarkson show right now I
am super excited because most people
don't know this I am a Kelly Clarkson
Stan not fan
Dan I love everything about her not just
her music but the person she is and so
I'm ready to get on stage have a good
time and talk about my brand new daytime
talk show coming out September 19th
right now all right here we go New York
last show last one
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]